Speaker 1: Folks, we have to now pray at the altar
of Joe Biden. Joe Biden has now reduced gas prices
22 days in a row. How did he do it? Obviously
because Joe Biden was to blame for higher gas
prices in every country. We must now praise Joe
Biden for this notable extended decline to gas
prices. I'm not actually being serious, but let me
tell you what it is that is going on and then we
will talk about it. Gas prices continue to drop.
Gas prices fell another $0.02 yesterday to 477
per gallon, according to the latest data. Down
$0.24 from the highest ever recorded level of $5
and one and a half cents last month. Gas prices
are on track to continue falling, though maybe
not fast enough for President Joe Biden, who
has criticized gas stations for keeping prices,
keeping prices high. So I tweeted sort of tongue
in cheek yesterday. Gas prices have declined
21 days in a row. How did Joe Biden do this? It
was completely satirical and with 50,000 likes
on that tweet as of this morning and maybe more
at this point in time. Most people understood it,
but not everybody. And some people thought I was
being serious and actually responded to me saying,
David, Joe Biden's irresponsible actions are
responsible for gas prices having gone up. But
he didn't do anything to lower them. Oh, okay. So
when a Democrat sees higher gas prices, it's their
fault. But when a Democrat sees declining gas
prices, it has nothing to do with that Democrat.
I've got it. Now, of course, you would probably be
asking one of the same questions I've been asking.
How is Joe Biden responsible for gas prices being
up in most countries over the last year? And how
can we now say he has nothing to do if that is his
major responsibility, which is incredible. One man
responsible for higher gas prices globally. Now
they go down and we say it has nothing to do with
him. That doesn't really make a lot of sense when
gas prices go down under, a Democrat conservative
say nothing. It's only when they go up. And
remember when prices were up under Donald Trump,
conservatives said nothing. They didn't complain.
I wonder why that is. So we can look at some
of the data here. GasBuddy is a good website
tracking this. As you can see, there was this peak
just under 502 per gallon, right around what
was that, mid-June, I guess we would call it.
And now gas prices down, not a crazy amount,
down about 5%. Now, there is a couple of
different things that are going on. One
of them is that the price of crude oil
has started to decline relatively significantly.
You might remember that briefly in March,
crude oil prices hit. What was this, $123 per
barrel? Crude oil is the source material for
what is eventually refined into gasoline that
we. Not me. I'm on electric now but that people
put in they're put in their cars. And speaking of
electric vehicles, there's a reason I bring that
up. Sustained high gas prices aren't particularly
good for the oil industry. You might think, well,
the higher the gas prices are, the more money they
make in the short and medium term, maybe. But if
the longer the gas prices are sustained at a high
level, the more people will say when it comes time
to replace their vehicle, I'm going to get off
gas altogether and go to an electric vehicle.
That's not good for the gas for the gasoline
industry. So we add that spike to about $123
per barrel in March. And then we had another
spike almost to the same level, $122 per barrel
about a month ago. And now, as of yesterday,
oil prices were all the way down to what does
this look like about 98, $99 per barrel? That's
a pretty significant decline. In a perfect world,
you would eventually see that same proportional
decline, about 17, 18% trickle down to gasoline.
It almost never happens. I'm reminded of
we've seen those who those of us who have
paid attention to or purchased
airline tickets over the last 15,
20 years, remember that every time that
jet fuel prices and crude oil prices go up,
airplane tickets go up, and sometimes there's
fuel surcharges and all these different things.
But then when the prices of jet fuel come down and
crude oil come down, those are rarely, if ever,
removed. They're sort of like permanent. And
we often don't see gas prices. Gas prices will
mirror the increases in oil prices, but they will
not mirror the decreases. But needless to say,
I don't think Joe Biden really has anything
to do with this. I didn't think Joe Biden
had anything to do with gas prices going up.
And I think he has essentially nothing to do
with gas prices going down. He released a little
bit of oil from the Strategic Petroleum Reserve.
Very modest impact. And that that's really the
tool other than, you know, going to war with an
oil rich nation or a gas tax holiday. Releasing
supply from the Strategic Petroleum Reserve is
one of the very few tools presidents have. This
stuff is global. This stuff is cyclical. It
tends to move relatively slowly. We're now it's
about three and a half weeks and it's like a 5%
decrease that we've seen. So my expectation and
I don't really make predictions that I would ever
suggest anyone make any financial decisions on my
expectation. Just based on what we've been seeing,
we've seen a slowdown in the growth through the
inflation rate. I expect to see that continuing
to come down. Gas prices are going to be a part
of that. And my my guess is and it's not a gas
I'm betting on. Remember, this is my guess. But in
terms of financial stuff, I'm just doing the same
thing I always do, just every month maintaining
my asset allocation. I'm not making any shorts or
investments in any commodities. I think over the
next six months we will see inflation taper off.
We will see gas prices continue to come down,
particularly as we are now. We are now at a
time that gas prices are often really expensive.
The summer driving season, as it's often called,
and I think six months from now, things are going
to look a lot more, more, more reasonable. What
we're now getting to, and we talked about
this yesterday with Pat on the bonus show,
is that first there were recession fears
because of such high prices and inflation. Now,
as we're seeing that start to taper a little
bit, there are recession fears over a demand
collapse. So either way, you'll find people who
have recession fears. I have no idea if we're
heading into a recession, but at least the
gas price numbers are starting to come down.
And I'm ready for all the right wingers
who blamed Biden for gas prices being up
to praise him, for them being down. I'm ready.
I'm not expecting it. I'm not holding my breath,
but I'm ready. If they want to be at least
consistent, let me know your thoughts. Let
me know what you're seeing locally. You
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.